the national women's soccer league just
kicked off its 10th season with two new
teams taking the field one of them the
angel city football club in los angeles
it was founded by actress natalie
portman and it is backed by a
star-studded group of women investors
creating the largest female lead
ownership group in professional sports
they are putting an emphasis on better
pay supporting players and of course
winning jamie yuka shows us how the team
is giving women sports a much needed
boost
a historic first goal
marking the first time in over a decade
the city of angels could rally behind a
women's professional soccer team
friday 22 thousand fans of all ages
sporting their pink and black gear faces
and hair filled los angeles bank of
california stadium to capacity
to witness the inaugural home match of
the angel city football club
the club made headlines for its majority
female ownership led by some of
hollywood's biggest stars and sports
legends such as abby womback mia hamm
serena williams and billie jean king
the powerhouse team of more than a
hundred investors is challenging the
industry by giving players a cut of the
money made from ticket sales better work
conditions and training for post-playing
careers you have been fighting for equal
pay
in terms of women getting paid for so
long forever so many people fight for
things in their life you're actually
getting to see it happen now what is
that like
makes me really happy and we're at a
tipping point these are a lot of the
dreams coming true that i used to dream
as a younger person
the club is already making player pay a
priority hometown hero kristin press was
the first to sign on to angel city for a
reported roughly 700 thousand dollar
contract over three seasons making her
one of the highest paid athletes in the
league
do you feel like this is the first time
in your career you do feel valued in
some ways yes this is belief
in our business this is belief that we
have value it's not charity to run a
women's soccer team it's a business it's
a business opportunity and i think that
is inherently different and it feels
different the team is looking to have
investors act more like founders and
engage at every level
one of those co-owners is olympic gold
medalist and gymnast sean johnson is
there something that angel city is
providing its players that you wish you
had when you were in gymnastics yes uh
one of the things i was most excited
about i mean everything i think as an
athlete myself from the olympics i knew
that usa gymnastics as a company was
using our name and likeness to profit
their industry
angel city obviously has created a
business out of this to start a movement
but a lot of those profits are actually
going directly to the athletes which i
think is really cool heavy investing in
female athletes has not been the norm
but a recent world cup win and a
successful high profile lawsuit for
equal pay is helping change the game for
the sport something angel city lead
investor alexis ohanian noticed while
watching the 2019 world cup final with
his wife tennis star serena williams and
their daughter olympia
i obviously have my own
sort of personal agenda for this because
little olympia was
running around during the 2019 world cup
final
in her alex morgan jersey
and i mentioned to my wife like wouldn't
it be nice one day if olympia played in
the world cup
and without missing a beat serena says
not until they pay her what she's worth
and i said okay challenge accepted the
challenge is deeply personal
angel city the girl dad's daughter is
now a co-owner at just four years old
why do you think women's soccer is
undervalued especially in the united
states frankly it's been treated
as a charity
i really believe the nwsl can be more
popular than the mls our
legacy of women's soccer in the united
states is that of greatness right it is
world cups it's olympic gold medals
as we start to show the viewership
numbers the ticket sales the sponsorship
revenue the merchandising all that stuff
more and more people will continue to
gravitate towards the greatness of the
women's game
other nwsl teams are duplicating the
celebrity investment model tennis star
naomi osaka invested in north carolina
courage and the washington spirit are
partially owned by chelsea clinton and
jenna bush hagar but to make all this
work press says it comes down to one
very basic sports concept
where do you think it goes from here
what's the goal at the end i think for
me the the goals to win the most
impactful thing we can do for the world
is to win because that's how they listen
for cbs mornings jamie yukas los angeles
speaking of winning it's a win-win when
you have a new franchise and shout out
to the largest female lead ownership
group in all of sports i i hope that we
see a lot more of that because
you know that type of foresight saying
you know what we are going to change the
way we look at revenue sharing with our
players because it will make our team a
better squad absolutely belief in the
business yeah not about charity it's
about championships and shout out to
angel city football club two to one they
beat the north carolina yeah and
speaking of that game play you can watch
the action from the nwsl's 10th season
on cbs cbs sports network and paramount
plus including the challenge cup final
this saturday